joining me here on the rich eisen show
is the man who um kicks everything off
right here on nbc sports on peacock
every single day um i'm i'm sorry to
inform him this way uh things have just
been so crazy that i did not text you
mike floria but i received your book
playmakers with your very kind note
written in an advanced copy of it where
all books can be acquired starting in
the middle of march when it comes out
but you can get it right now on amazon
and everything else i greatly appreciate
that michael and uh i i appreciate you
mentioning it of course every time that
i'm on and uh we we still keep trying to
sell as many
as we can the angst continues
don't worry it's no stop stop stop but
at any rate uh i've already started
playmakers too
good lord
playmakers focuses on 20 seasons i can
do playmakers too based on one
okay let's jump into it um you were the
first person i wanted to reach out to
since you are the perfect cross-section
of football and uh lawyering and the
legal front what did you make of brian
flores's
lawsuit filed yesterday
the rooney rule was put in place in 2002
rich due to the credible threat of
litigation
from cyrus mary and the late johnny
cochran that's what got the rooney rule
enacted now i don't know that they had
somebody ready to go dennis green was
between jobs with the vikings and the
cardinals at the time i could see him
being willing given that he was mid 50s
at the time trading the rest of his
career to be the pioneer in a case that
you could argue needed to be brought at
some point in the 20 years since then
what's really happened what progress has
been made what can you do to ultimately
convince the owners of these teams
to do
something
that approaches what objectively could
be considered the right thing when you
consider just the raw numbers i mean the
raw numbers speak for themselves but i
think they never dreamed that anyone
would trade in or at least risk trading
in the balance of his coaching career to
be the one who pushes this cause now
maybe
maybe the risk is unfounded maybe brian
flores will still be a coach maybe
somebody will look past it maybe he
won't get the colin kaepernick black
ball treatment moving forward
but you at least come to the table if
you're brian flores knowing
that you are risking that when you do
this and i think the league never
anticipated that anyone would do it i
didn't think anyone would do it and i
definitely didn't think somebody under
40 would do it i thought it would be a
guy close to the end of his career so um
now that he has done it what happens
well the first step
will be an effort by the league to force
everything into arbitration these
coaching contracts all have a clause
requiring any disputes to be resolved
through
an arbitration process that conveniently
and strategically requires that the
commissioner or his designee will
resolve all claims which is not the best
way to get
fair and balanced justice from any type
of a system and and i'm sure that fight
will happen first it's it's the first
shot that they fired at john gruden and
it'll be the first shot that they fire
at brian flores and if it happens the
problem is for those of us who are very
curious about how this all transpires
what occurs what evidence comes out
we'll never have an open court
proceeding there'll never be an
opportunity to really understand what
the evidence is what the arguments are
what the outcome would be i mean i
assume we'll know the outcome but we
won't know much more than that
if this thing ultimately goes to
arbitration but that'll be the first
fight and then at some point he'll have
to prove his case just like colin
kaepernick took depositions got
documents he'll have to prove his case
and along the way
he hopes and his lawyers suggested
earlier today on cnn that that other
coaches are going to actually join him
in this effort and that would be amazing
if it happens because there's strength
in strength in numbers the more black
coaches who who are plaintiffs named
plaintiffs in this lawsuit the harder it
will be
to blackball all of them and and we'll
see if that comes to fruition and maybe
others will decide to join him and arm
and arm
they will protect each other and maybe
advance their long-term career interests
well i mean and as i mentioned um and i
you know needed need to repeat it every
single time because um not
there's nothing worse than than racism
there's nothing worse than the judging
somebody by the color of their skin and
certainly um judging them adversely and
affecting their professional
uh abilities through because of the
color of your skin but him saying
as well in this whole process that
steven ross asked him to not only tank
but tamper as well but tanking
through money i mean what what happens
with that one
and you know that really doesn't fit
with the rest of the case but this is
the risk you take when you invite this
kind of bombshell litigation it's
possible that there'll be some related
allegation that that could potentially
take over especially in the short term
this idea that stephen ross allegedly
offering a hundred thousand dollars for
each loss in 2019 and i know i believe i
firmly believe
that stephen ross wanted to tank wire to
wire in 2019 so he'd have the first pick
in 2020. originally that was for
tuatanga by low after he broke his hip
and joe burrow emerged it became joe
burrow as the object of steven ross's
affection and he couldn't trade up from
number five to number one to get him and
i'm sure that the success of joe burrow
has stuck in his craw because he wanted
his team to be in position to get that
number one overall pick and also just
let me just jump in here though the five
that he was at was because the texans
were the ones that were performing so
poorly and miami had that draft choice
because of uh one of the trades that
bill o'brien made involving laramie
tunsil right so so he he had that the
dolphins had that pick it was their own
that according to flores they were
trying to improve all the way to number
one and that wasn't even close because i
mean it was obvious from the very
beginning that flores had this team in
the right direction based on early on
they lost 59 to 10 to the ravens in week
one then they lost again micka
fitzpatrick won it out and got traded
and i think at some point brian flores
realized this full season tank thing
isn't going work and i'm not doing it
i'm just not doing it and i'd speculated
after he got fired that that may have
been
the first moment where the relationship
between ross and flores got wobbly and
based on this lawsuit it seems like
that's exactly what transpired but you
know rich i don't know how the league
doesn't aggressively investigate
that and then the follow from hugh
jackson the former browns coach who
suggested along with the executive
director his foundation that bonuses
were paid
to browns coaches and executives for
losing in 2016 and 2017 and they were
awful both years and they got the number
one overall pick in the draft which
became miles garrett and baker mayfield
respectively
you have to investigate it you have to
take it seriously in the age of
legalized gambling the idea even if it's
not a tim donahue situation where
someone is
engineering the outcome of a game for
gambling
interests
but you're still deliberately not
winning according to allegation you're
not winning games because of a strategic
reason and the nfl always pushes this
idea that every game every team in every
game always trying to win we know that
there's a flaw in that thinking once
you're eliminated from playoff
contention what do you really win by
winning games what what do you gain by
losing well you get a higher draft pick
and you see what those picks are worth
when teams trade look at what the 49ers
gave up to go from 12 to 3 last year it
happens every year what washington once
gave up to go from six to two to get rg
three you give up a lot those those
those spots have value
they just have to do something about it
they can't brush it under the rug and
they already have congress on them for
the washington football team workplace
misconduct investigation and the
potential that there was a cover-up
there
i think it's just a matter of time
before roger goodell gets another letter
seeking information about stephen ross
jimmy haslam and possibly pointing
toward a hearing where people are going
to have to answer some tough questions
in an open committee chamber and what
about finding out who texted bill
belichick right because it's that
i mean how about the fact that
belichick's phone is potentially
involved in this oh it's amazing and and
to have
a quote from bill belichick with
an f word
unredacted
as and and look i've been involved in
plenty of lawsuits on both sides
representing the defendant representing
the plaintiff and
you know you have to they call it the
style of the case brian flores
plaintiff versus nfl and
you know and there's a line and usually
right under the line it says complaint
right under the line in this one is in
bold face
bill belichick f-bomb
where he's acknowledging he made a
mistake by congratulating brian flores
instead of brian dabal for becoming the
next coach of the giants before brian
flores ever even interviewed
for the job of the new york giants and
that's when flores realized something
was amiss and you had to have belichick
pulled into it his phone pulled into it
he's going to have to testify this thing
is going to be
a mess for the nfl regardless of where
it plays out and
uh it it's it's it's something that
that is going to last for a while unless
the nfl resolves it quickly and you know
they're not wired to do this i heard you
talking about the statement earlier the
nfl saying right out of the gates the
claims are without merit how do you know
they're without merit how do you know
well that but that tells us they're
going to fight that's the clue they're
going to fight
it would be wise for them to try to
resolve it
but they're going to fight it and
they're going to fight it and uh you
know i think that was the attitude they
originally had with the saint louis
litigation and six years later they
ended up paying 790 million so uh and i
guess to if you will put a uh button on
it for the moment then um what what what
what could be the resolution to it i
mean because i i was reading through it
and flores uh through his legal uh
counsel was asking for what committees
to be set up and demand that owners put
in writing exactly why somebody was
fired and
um as well as uh create a money pool for
uh what um
uh uh
for for
the i guess
uh promotion uh of of
um
candidates of color i i i'm trying to
figure out what what what is
what he's looking for and what could be
done to actually improve the rooney rule
which i think everybody involved agrees
needs improvement for sure some of that
may have been for the benefit of the
media look what you get in court is
typically typically he's asked for what
they call injunctive relief where a
court says that you must do x y and z
and first you got to get a finding of
liability the usual outcome is the
payment of monetary damages but through
a settlement process
you you get whatever the two sides agree
to and he could ask for certain terms
unrelated to the payment of any money
and if they can reach an agreement then
that's all that matters but first the
league has to be motivated to reach an
agreement this gets into how the legal
business works look the firms that
represent companies like this and i
worked at one when my legal career first
started back in 1991 and the managing
partner the firm was visiting our office
and the thing he said that i will never
forget we aspired i represent cost
insensitive clients which means they're
not going to complain about how much the
bill is every month they don't care if
we put umpteen lawyers on the file you
want big cases with big companies with
big stakes and that's how you make your
money as one of these firms and you
don't make your money
if right out of the gates
the big client in the big stakes
litigation says maybe we should resolve
this and make it go away so this is all
pointing toward a fight not a resolution
and they'll probably regret it at the
end of the day hey maybe you know what
maybe it'll all work out for maybe
they'll probably rich i mean
the the evidence has been hiding in
plain sight it's obvious to anyone who's
paying attention there's an issue with
the representation of black coaches as
head coaches given the number of black
players a number of black assistant
coaches historically it has been abysmal
and it was just a matter of time before
somebody decided i'm going to be the one
to put my name on the fight against the
nfl for something that we all know we
all know it's been a problem so
it it's this this is a mess for the nfl
and i don't like how they've handled it
so far
we'll see by next wednesday when the
commissioner meets with the media
at uh the demo field at the nfl network
headquarters at sofi stadium we'll see
what he has to say when he's asked some
questions about it that's going to be an
occasion for him to earn some of that 65
million a year so let me let me ask you
this then um what about the idea of of
floors getting hired i mean if you want
to just put it in brass tacks a win-win
around is that number one flores
is employed
as he deserves to be two uh an
organization gets an outstanding coach
and three um you know that organization
might get some heat amongst some of the
owners when they walk into
uh a membership room but in essence that
is a way to tell whoever's adjudicating
this case guy got hired so
what about that well and listen rich one
of the great strategies from
the defense standpoint if you believe
that
you are in the wrong and that you are
facing a significant outcome
through trial
you offer the plan of a job and i've had
that happen with my clients in the past
and sometimes they've taken it and i
think that sometimes the company didn't
expect them to take it but they could
offer brian flores and see this gets
difficult for the nfl gets into
antitrust issues because these are all
32 separate businesses and the league
can't really tell or hint or advise but
but if for example the saints would
offer brian flores their head coaching
job that seems to be the team right now
that's considering it if they'd offer
him the job now if he'd say no
well why are you saying no you know that
that becomes an issue in the litigation
hey you had an opportunity we offered
you well it wasn't real you know it was
only because i sued that becomes a
separate skirmish
or he says yes and you know does that
take some of the steam out of the
litigation but hopefully hopefully the
saints consider him i mean ideally and
we know ideally doesn't happen very
often but ideally they consider him and
they make a decision on who their best
candidate is regardless of whether or
not he's pursued this litigation a lot
of people out there that think it's okay
to retaliate against someone who's sued
like how dare you sue we're never going
to hire you again that's a separate
violation of the law if it happens you
can't retaliate against somebody who has
advanced their legal rights and uh
hopefully he won't be blackballed and
maybe just maybe maybe the saints and
you know the saints have issues with the
league office dating back to bountygate
maybe the saints think they're sticking
to the league office a little bit if
they would hire him but it would
actually help the league i think if
brian flores got back in sooner rather
than later
the last one for you outside of all this
mike florio uh is my alma mater losing
its coach
well you know he wants to go i think and
i've been paying attention to this ever
since his name was first connected to
the raiders it was always a sense that
it was coming from his perspective
that he he's ready to go back to the nfl
he wants to win a super bowl he's 58
he's only got so many more spins
before he's going to be done coaching he
wants to go back the connection to
quezia dofo mensah the new general
manager of the vikings who was with jim
harbaugh for two years in san francisco
the last two years the two ugly years
between him and trent balke and maybe
him and jed york
well question fomento comes out of it
thinking hey this is this is my guy if i
become a gm
and it'll be interesting to see what the
vikings do i know they've got some
concern because mike zimmer was kind of
an in your face negative
coach
jim harbaugh is very intense
i think it's different in how he
approaches the players and john harbaugh
is just like jim and john has thrived in
baltimore since 2008 but i think jim
wants it and i think there's a sense
that that jim knows he's got to go to
this interview today
and convince them to hire him but 44 19
and one in four years with the 49ers and
he took a team that was six and 10
in 2010 to the brink of the super bowl
in 2011 without the benefit of an
offseason that was the year of the
lockout he shows up early august first
meeting with the team he gets him
buttoned up and squared away and but for
a couple of kyle williams muffs against
the giants in the nfc championship game
they're in the super bowl against the
patriots in 2011.
and um and then it's amazing you
mentioned trent balckey you know he was
uh in the front office in san francisco
and now he's uh reemerged in
jacksonville
and
is is he an impediment or an enhancement
for them to get a job a head coach there
it just seems to me
who wouldn't be jumping at trying to get
their hands on trevor lawrence in a in a
town that's
got no state tax right
and um an owner who's about to pour a
ton of money into facilities and no
you know local media breathing down your
neck on mass like what a gig that is
down there and why is that job still
open the concern has been from the
moment it was reported that trent balke
is going to stay as the gm that he'll be
an impediment i've heard that there have
been coaching candidates that have said
no thank you to invitations to interview
for the job and there's there's a weird
sense and i don't know this but i'm
trying to piece together the reporting
that's being done because at one point
mike jorecki who's covered the cardinals
for years reported that
that uh adrian wilson
who's now an executive with the
cardinals and had played for them for a
long period of time he was going to be
the next gm and byron leflich was going
to be the next head coach and the
jaguars have done nothing to really
message or push back on any of this
stuff i get the impression
that shad khan the owner of the jaguars
is giving trent balcke an opportunity to
find someone who would be better than
byron leftwich in shod khan's eyes and
if he can't it's going to be balky out
and it's going to be adrian wilson and
byron leftwich in and rick spielman's in
the mix now too but i saw somebody say
he could possibly be the team president
not the gm but i think balky's doing
everything he can to put something
together that gets shot khan to decide
to go that way instead of this left
witch and adrian wilson package deal wow
all right and and is this lawsuit um
that brian flores last one we're gonna
put the brakes on the texans hiring josh
mccown who has uh apparently a second
interview there and they love him
he has no experience as we know coaching
um
and you know we we've seen that work at
other levels not really in the nfl
but is that
what what happens there now in houston
welcome
you know one of my first thoughts
yesterday rich was brian flores maybe
should have waited until all these other
jobs were filled because it would
strengthen his case
if there are no black coaches hired in
this cycle but in a weird sort of way he
possibly has done some of his colleagues
a favor because some of these teams may
may decide
we need to from a pr standpoint it's not
really going to help the lawsuit defense
because it's going to be
you know obvious and flora's loyal say
well come on that's meaningless you did
that after
after we filed a lawsuit of course
that's why you did it from a pr
standpoint there's value
and you can't have the dust settle on
this cycle and have one black coach in
the nfl you can't and it looks like
that's the direction it's going but this
mccount thing
i i don't think that brian flores will
surface as the coach of the texans
there's a a section of his complaint
that specifically targets them so you
know i don't think they're going to
forget about that quickly but this
mccount thing i have people say well you
know he was quarterback for 16 years in
the nfl he's he's quite qualified to be
a head coach right out of the gate why
aren't the saints interviewing drew
brees to be the head coach then why
didn't the chargers interview phillip
rivers to be the head coach i mean you
can go down the list of guys who played
in the nfl and actually played weren't
backups
and they're never mentioned as potential
out of the gates
no experience required
nfl head coach it's offensive to all
coaches
of all races
that have been working and working and
working and understand what it takes to
potentially be a head coach someday
because there's only so many of these
jobs the supply outweighs the demand
there are people out there who if you
give them that job they'll figure out
how to do it and the notion that they
would give and i like josh mccown but
the notion that the texan would give him
that job with no experience is offensive
to anyone out there who's been busting
their ass to try to position themselves
for one of these rare opportunities mike
florio greatly appreciate as always uh
we'll see you about out here next week
and again everybody get playmakers uh in
advance the book comes out in march but
uh you can get it where all books are
acquired right now mike florio and how
the nfl really works parenthetically and
doesn't thanks for the time here thanks
rich siepel you bet that's mike florio
here hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here